all right no now that Apple under its
gay CEO Tim Cook has has made the
largest quarterly profit in history from
now on the phrase you're so gay means
congratulations on your success
I just got that promotion dude you're so
gay new rules stop calling these estate
sales you live in Canoga Park not [ __ ]
[ __ ] skims your farm you're selling old
clothes and VHS copies of the police
academy movies great you're not lord of
the manor you're too cheap to donate to
Goodwill
I know new rule of Kim jong-un wants to
be taken seriously as a tyrant he has to
stop plucking his eyebrow man at your
war face not your vagina that's good
that's good
neural someone has to tell - honey TP
who's accused of trying to smuggle a
heroin laced Bible into an Ohio Jail
that that stuff is dangerous I mean sure
it provides a euphoric sense of
well-being but then you're you're hooked
and you lose touch with reality and and
heroines not good for you either that
either way
it's my new role it's time to admit that
men who are into S&M don't look like
this
they look like this
you